all of that hard work all of the
mistakes that i made in the beginning i
mean
you can go back and you can watch my
videos they're not great i had
a lot to learn i had to learn the
algorithm seo on youtube
and i also had to learn what made me
different and if you're at the point
where you're like my videos aren't
anything special i don't know why
someone would watch my video over
someone else's video
you really need to hone in and figure
out what you uniquely
like what do you have to actually bring
to the table
did you know that in the us alone women
owned businesses
generated over 1.8 trillion dollars last
year
and the number of female youtube
creators
making over 100 000 a year
is on the rise according to recent stats
now i'm so excited because today
i am bringing you behind the scenes of
our growth video live
virtual conference i'm sitting down with
two amazing female content creators
vanessa lau and catherine manning my
name is heather torres
and you're listening to the think media
podcast the number one podcast to help
you grow your influence on youtube
and then turn that influence into a high
impact and a high
profit youtube channel now in today's
interview
i'll be speaking with vanessa lau and
after quitting her nine to five
she started a youtube channel and
amassed a digital reach of over
456 000 subscribers on youtube and 160
000 followers on instagram
and grew her business to over a million
dollars in revenue
all while making an impact on millennial
women who want to grow their coaching
business
and we're also joined by katherine
manning who in just
one year who went from being a digital
marketing consultant
to a beginner blogger to a full-time
online entrepreneur
with over 380 000 subscribers
several viral videos like how to start a
youtube channel and a channel that's
generating over
thirty thousand dollars a month she now
helps people
just like you follow their passion and
grow their audience online
we're going to be sharing tactical and
tangible tips that you can use on your
youtube channel
we're going to jump into today's
featured conversation from growth video
live
2020.
[Music]
so uh let's go to just jump into this
vanessa
you've been on youtube now for a little
bit over a year and you
have just taken youtube by storm there
are so many people on the chat right now
that are lighting up vanessa's here
so take it back and tell me the journey
of what it was like to get to where you
are today kind of walk me through what
that looked like for you
yeah i always like to say that it took
me six years to start my channel
it got to a point where every new year's
i was putting start a youtube channel
start a youtube channel on my new year's
resolution and it wasn't until
i found myself at a 905 that i wasn't
enjoying i was getting the promotions i
got the dream titles
where i realized i wasn't really
fulfilled and it was time to take the
leap and do something different and so
i quit my job without a plan i resigned
without a plan and during that time
frame
i had so much time on my hands it got to
a place where there's literally no
excuses to not start that channel and so
i started the channel i started sharing
things that i was going through
and lo and behold eventually my videos
started picking up
i started to pivot niches as well
and now we have a multiple seven-figure
business
because i was smart to monetize and do
all those things with my channel
and it's been a blast since so
awesome and i can't wait to dive into
all the juicy details of how you did it
how you got started and how you can help
other people but
catherine you went from being a blogger
and then you were helping people with
social media now you're doing youtube
full-time
walk me through what that journey was
like for you to get to where you are
today
yeah similar to vanessa i started
because i was just really unhappy with
my career i wasn't feeling fulfilled and
i was just
miserable with so many aspects of my
life and at the time
i was terrified of showing my face which
i get that comment all the time
what do i do if i don't want to show my
face in my videos and stuff so
i actually got started with my blog
first because that was a way for me to
remain
anonymous and i got started as the
content bug and over time i started to
share my face more and more and i
learned that
video was really the move i think it's a
lot easier to connect with your audience
over video
and i wanted to start a youtube channel
so i started on youtube
three years ago it took me a long time
to grow
but within the last year it's been
absolutely crazy
yeah and both of you guys really have
exploded over the last year and we're
gonna dive into what that looks like
vanessa
if someone wants to get started today
what advice do you have for someone
that is scared and nervous to just start
yeah i've got like three tips one of
them is mindset related two of them are
tactical so the first thing is you gotta
get your mindset right because i know
for me
and i said this earlier it took me six
years to finally do the dang thing
and start my channel and what i like to
tell a lot of people now
is the best time to start was last year
or five years ago
but the second best time to start your
channel is today right i see a lot of
new creators they
beat themselves up thinking oh i should
have done it in 2012.
i should have done it in 27 2007 when
youtube was poppin and when the
algorithm was better
you know algorithms will always change
whether it's youtube
instagram ticktalk technology will
always change but it doesn't change the
fact that you still don't have your
youtube channel up and running
right and so the first thing is you got
to stop making excuses and you got to
make this your year
of starting that channel the second
thing and this is something that i
covered
you know on in my session yesterday so
if you haven't seen my session you
aren't signed up for growth video
definitely definitely make sure you get
the replay tickets and stuff
because in my session i talk all about
how a common mistake a lot of new
content creators also make
is feeling that intense pressure to
already find a niche
and to already try to pigeon the whole
themselves into a quote-unquote niche
because there's so many content creators
that share that advice including myself
but if i really step take a step back
and how i started i was very broad at
first i created content based off of a
target audience
that has very different interests and so
i wasn't just talking about
social media i was talking about
budgeting social media
quitting your job um you know how to get
a promotion at your job i was doing a
lot of things that cater
to a millennial audience that just
graduated college
and that allowed me to test out what
topics i even liked doing
it allowed me to tap into my creativity
and it also gave me enough space for
youtube to tell me
what people wanted and that's how i was
able to kind of pivot and niche down
eventually
to instagram and that's kind of what i
do now if you guys don't know me my
my channel is really based off of giving
people social media tips but it wasn't
always like that and it really took a
lot of experimentation
to finally figure out what the secret
sauce was for me
uh which was a mixture of things that i
like to talk about but also a mixture of
what the youtube algorithm picked up for
other people
and then another thing the third tip
that i have for you
is if you fail to plan you plan to fail
the amount of times that i just turned
on my camera when i first started
expecting that a beautiful youtube video
would you know happen
it didn't happen every single time i'd
have to pack up my equipment
and then just give up and the reason why
is because i didn't have
a plan i didn't have an outline of what
i was gonna say i didn't plan
ahead i only planned the first video
let's say but not the next two
and so if you're starting out you don't
need to over plan but at least have an
idea
of what your first three videos are
gonna look like you know what you're
gonna talk about do a
bullet point method or something because
the last thing that you want is turning
on that camera
and just realizing oh my goodness i
don't really know what to say
and so that can really help the second
thing too that i mentioned of making
sure you have at least three videos
planned
the reason why i say this is because you
want to gain momentum
you want to practice being consistent a
mistake that i made when i started was i
only planned
the first video and then i didn't
realize how much work that first video
was
and so i immediately gave up afterwards
and i wasn't consistent
until i at least had an idea for the
next three videos
and trust me when you turn on that
camera and you know you have a plan
it just feels a lot better and then i'm
also going to throw in a bonus tip
because some of you guys who might be
starting out you might be thinking okay
i
know i need to plan ahead but i don't
know what content ideas to do i don't
really know
you know what i should talk about one
thing that i like to do when i was
starting out was i literally
looked at other people who were doing
videos
that i wanted to do and i ranked and i
filter their videos from most popular
to least popular and i kind of looked at
what was performing for other people
now one thing i want to mention is you
don't want to
copy other creators you don't want to
just copy and paste what other people
are doing
because that's the last way that you can
build authority in your space fast what
i recommend
is looking at their videos or looking at
the topics that are ranking really well
for them
but not watching their video just taking
the topic and putting your own spin on
it
instead of spending all your hours
creeping your competitors and watching
your video
watching their videos even to this day i
don't watch other people's videos
but i do pay attention to what is
performing
with other people's channels so those
are the three and a half tips that i
have for you
when you're starting out that really
helped me really gain that momentum on
my channel
so good vanessa i hope you're taking
notes i hope you've got a journal out i
hope you are writing these things down
because these women
are super smart when it comes to growing
an online business and catherine
i want to pass the question to you
because you said that you know you went
from being faceless
meaning that it was really about the
content bug and you were into writing
to then shifting into actually putting
yourself on camera
what tips do you have for someone who
may be a blogger right now or
you know is in a podcasting space but
really needs to
turn on the camera and press record what
advice do you have for someone
i think so for me it was really hard to
make that shift i mean i
started my brand i started the content
bug and i told no one
actually my family found out because
they ended up finding my new instagram
account and my sister found my pinterest
account which i was promoting
my blog post on my pinterest and that's
how they ended up finding out about my
brand i was
so terrified to tell anyone and once i
got to the point where
i my family had found out my friends
kind of knew
i became a little bit more comfortable
now it doesn't happen overnight you're
still going to worry about what other
people think of you like
are they going to judge me for doing
this thing and wanting to be an
influence or wanting to be a youtuber
that's still going to be a thought in
your mind but
it has to get to the point where you
have to do it for you
and that's i have a tattoo right here
that says for me
and it's just a constant reminder like
you have to live your life for yourself
so
for me when i switched from going as a
blogger to a youtuber
i just realized the importance of
connecting with your audience
i felt like with blog posts i could only
get my personality across
so much through text it's a lot easier
to really connect with people
and be vulnerable and be authentic on
camera and i think that connection is
absolutely huge so
the transition is not going to happen
overnight for me
it was one of those things like vanessa
said you just have to cut your excuses
and do the dang thing and
one thing that i would recommend for you
guys is while you have the courage
while you're like yes i'm gonna start
this youtube channel i'm gonna do this
dang thing
actually do it and then hold yourself
accountable to it so one thing that
really works for me
is i created an uploading schedule and
it was the same thing when i had my blog
i said okay
every oh my gosh i think it was every
tuesday and it's funny i'm still on
every tuesday
i was like every tuesday i'm gonna
launch a blog post no matter what and
then that turned
into youtube and i was like no matter
what i have to upload this youtube video
it's a non-negotiable and you have to
make that commitment to yourself
and don't break that promise
really staying on that content schedule
is like you said it's critical and it
builds those muscles
of becoming a content creator and
vanessa i'd love to hear from you
because you know a lot of times when
people come to youtube
they uh they maybe not they may not know
what types of videos they want to create
or they're making videos that are safe
right they start making those safe
videos and both you and katherine have
made some pretty vulnerable
videos i'd love for you to maybe just
share what it takes
what mindset you have to be in to be
able to actually
share your voice authentically on
youtube so you can stand out
yeah something that i like to say is
that it's important to be
a leader and not a follower
followers follow leaders they don't
follow other followers and in order to
be a leader in the space
there are different elements right there
are elements where you deliver massive
value
but people stand behind leaders because
of their
authenticity because they are relatable
because they show that they aren't
super human i know for a lot of you guys
in the chat box you guys have either
really loved following me or catherine
because
we have shown these other struggles or
these difficulties or these challenges
that we have put out there on the
internet and maybe that
helped you figure out this is my person
that i want to trust here on youtube
because i see myself in them
and it's really important that you
understand in this vast social media
space there's always going to be someone
that's going to be looking up to you but
they're just waiting for you
to start that channel they're waiting
for you to put your message out there
they're waiting for you to share your
stories
you know on social media here yes
there's the tips there's the cheat codes
and
the hacks and everything but at the end
of the day we're all human
and people really really love seeing
that authenticity
shine with your channel so it's not
always cookie cutter content
oh man thank you so much for that advice
vanessa and it's so true right you just
have to
you just have to step up and lead if you
are liking this video
go ahead and hit the like button right
now and if you know someone
that should be watching this video make
sure you share it with them as well now
catherine i want to pass the question
off to you because you
make some really creative videos and you
really take people behind the scenes
in your content creation it's not
necessarily just talking head
and it's not always i would say the
pretty production right you just kind of
let your hair down
and you really just speak to your girl
on camera
tell me what it was like actually having
to get to the point to be able to make
those kind of vulnerable
videos it was a journey
it was a process one of the questions i
get asked all the time is how are you so
comfortable on camera
and i have left my very first video i
ever created
live on my youtube channel so you guys
can go back and watch and see where i
started because
where i started i was afraid i was
terrified i had no idea what i was doing
and at first i felt comfortable just
kind of showing up as me i feel like my
personality did not come off that way
obviously i was very
aware that there was a camera there but
i wasn't afraid to show up with no
makeup on my hair
just in a mess like i that's who i was
and that's
how i look most days and i wasn't afraid
of that until it got to the point where
i felt like i saw all their youtubers
have a full face of makeup on their hair
was always perfect and i was like i have
to be
this perfect youtuber because that's
what does well on the platform that's
what i thought
i had to do to succeed on youtube and
i did that for a while until i got to a
point where i was like i'd rather have
people
hate me for being me compared to being
someone that i'm not
just because i think it's going to get
me from here to here
so now i mean i'm not wearing much
makeup i've cried on camera like i try
to share
the real stuff because i think that's
far more relatable yeah it really is
that is really what connects people and
i'm right there with you i'm i mean like
i have makeup on right now because we're
in the middle of a conference you know
but like
normally it is like sweatpants mom
happening all the time so
uh i want to get into that a little bit
uh not sweatpants mom but i want to ask
you
vanessa as you transition from a nine to
five having a boss
to actually running your own company
which just started with just you
how was that transition how do you it's
not necessarily a balance but what does
that look like for you are you
a time management person are you a
procrastinator like give us the reel
on what it's like to be your own boss
i am the biggest procrastinator so i
don't know anyone in the chat box likes
like horoscopes and stuff i'm a tourist
we're super lazy
i'm also an enfp i also like them all
talk no action kind of girl until the
very last second
um but hiring a team was definitely
scary at first
um and i think it's important that you
start outsourcing
once you realize that this is what i
want to do this is what i want to commit
to
when you are a solopreneur or when you
are starting this out
this journey by yourself there's going
to be a period where you're wondering to
yourself do i even like doing this
and it's really important to spot check
with yourself you have to ask yourself
okay
if these videos were performing well if
these um if i was making money with this
would i still give up right because a
lot of people sometimes they'll
automatically give up
because the videos aren't performing or
they're not monetized yet
or they're not finding the success that
they thought they would and every time i
hear someone say that i always ask them
if it was successful and if you were
making money and if
these videos were performing would you
still be giving up and most times it's
no and for me it's really important to
kind of think about that before you
outsource and figure out okay
do you actually genuinely enjoy doing
what you're doing right now and do you
feel like you want to take on the
responsibility
of paying someone else to be a part of
your team and help you build that vision
and for me even during that period of
time where my videos weren't performing
as well as i thought
i wasn't making a dime i was still
getting up
maybe not consistently because sometimes
i'd be tired and stuff like because i'm
human
but i wouldn't trade it for anything
else i wouldn't go back to a nine to
five i wouldn't be
someone else's employee i would still
want to do this
right and so that's the spot check that
you want to make with yourself as you're
starting because hiring a team
and outsourcing is no joke right now
you're responsible
for someone else and you're bringing
them on to your boat and you're going
towards the
destination right and so that's
important when it comes to i think
heather you asked like what was it like
how did it feel like
i can also share with you guys the first
person that i outsourced and that was a
video editor and it was the best thing
ever
but i also want to say that it's really
important especially as a content
creator
for you to do everything yourself when
you're first starting out
and get the hang of being a one-man show
or a one-woman
show because that's gonna help you so
much when you're
off-boarding your tasks to someone else
and also
it doesn't create a lot of liabilities
it doesn't create a lot of risk
if those people leave at least you still
know how to do everything
or at least how to do most things and so
i highly recommend for those of you who
are listening to this question don't
feel pressured to hire yet
continue creating your videos continue
you know editing your videos continue
doing everything
a to z from xero to post production to
everything with your youtube channel
because it's going to help you so much
and it's going to help you build
stronger teams in the future
and then when it comes to time
management um
um i it's funny because heather and
catherine and i
were we were just talking about this
earlier and i was saying how
it's such a luxury sometimes when you
are a solopreneur and you're doing
things by yourself
because you can just wake up and decide
not to do things
you can change deadlines you can do all
those things
and there's very little consequences to
your actions versus once you start
hiring more people and you're more
responsible for other people
then now you've really got to be
organized you've really got to have
deadlines and stick to them because it's
going to affect
other people on your team and i would be
as close to saying that i am more
organized
now than when i was back then when i ran
my youtube channel on my own
because now i'm responsible for other
people and so that's why earlier on we
were talking about the importance of
planning catherine said this i said this
heather touched on this the more
organized you can be now
it's a lot easier when you start
outsourcing because you're building that
muscle of consistency
and now other people can happily be able
to do their jobs
because you are being consistent and you
are being organized
yes and the chat was lighting up with
procrastinators i feel you
i know what it's like i mean i feel like
i lived the procrastinated life
for so long until like vanessa said
there were other people that depended
on me and so if you're in that solar
preneur season right now
i want you to start thinking about what
is it going to be like when you do bring
your first va on your first virtual
assistant your first editor
because i know you have big dreams and i
know that you want this to go
somewhere and so i don't want you to be
thinking small i want you to be thinking
big and that's exactly what catherine
did and so katherine i'd love to ask you
you know one thing i love about watching
your channel is that you really talk
about how this
is your career you've chosen this as a
career and you
treat it like a business and that's why
you've all seen the success that you've
seen
so i'd love to know what was that like
for you going from traditional you know
you went to college and then
you started working but then what did it
what was it like for you to flip into
this full-time content creator role
it was really really rough for me so i'm
very honest on my youtube channel
it took me a long time to grow and even
recently i shared my journey of how i
built up
credit card debt trying to be a
full-time youtuber i
really dove into this earlier than i
should have and
i made the transition so i graduated
from college i started working as a
digital marketing consultant and then i
started my blog as a side hustle so
i was working my butt off i was working
a nine-to-five job at nights i was
working on my blog
and then weekends i remember on saturday
i would wake up at five in the morning
and i would just hustle because i was
trying to grow that thing and i knew
that
that was going to be my future that was
going to be the direction of my career
like you said so
i worked my butt off and then it got to
the point where i became a freelancer i
started taking on clients and
learning how to balance i needed to get
client work done because i needed to
make money but at the same time i had to
create youtube videos because
that was going to be the growth of my
brand and even though
it took me a year and a half to get
monetized on youtube i created
so many videos without making any money
for a long time
i knew that continuing to be consistent
with that and continuing to go in that
direction
that was going to get me where i wanted
to go so i had to take on clients
to make money so that i could do the
dang thing and
if you were just now getting started if
you are doing this as a side hustle
if you are working your butt off and
you're not sure
how to turn it into a business or you're
not sure if you're going the right
direction
the one thing i can say to you is be
persistent
be determined and don't ever give
up on yourself there are going to be
hard seasons there was a hard season
where
i built up credit card debt and i'm not
proud of that and i wouldn't recommend
any of you guys do that but it was a
part of my journey and it was something
that i had to do to get myself to where
i am today so
be determined make promises to yourself
that you are not going to break like for
me that was my uploading schedule upload
one video a week
stick to it guys do not break it and
that's going to actually get you to
where you want to go with your youtube
channel and help you to be able to
actually
turn it into a business like heather
just said
yeah and that's exactly what catherine
has done you know she stuck to that
schedule she kept uploading videos
whether they were easy whether they were
there i mean katherine i just have to
say i just love watching the creativity
that you put into your work
and it really is art and so i just want
to say thank you so much for
staying consistent with that and for a
while you didn't actually see
a lot of growth but then bam it hit
so walk me through really quick what
that was like but before you do that
katherine i want to let people know
we're going to jump into a q a
so if you have questions you can leave
them in the chat below and i'm going to
start pulling them
up for catherine or for vanessa so
catherine
what was that like for you because you
kind of went on a trend right you were
getting progress getting progress and
then
it hit so tell me about what that was
like
yeah so i started my youtube channel in
october of 2017.
i ended 2018 with 300 some subscribers
so i was working for
over a year on my youtube channel i was
being consistent i was uploading two
videos a week and i had only gained 300
subscribers in a year
and then in 2019 i decided to take it a
bit more seriously i
niched down a little bit i started
focusing on three main topics and
i just really got to work and i tried to
improve the quality of my videos that's
when i bought my first
camera for my channel and it really
wasn't
until i was on youtube for two whole
years and
this is what like i want this to be
motivation for you guys
last year at this time i had maybe 2 000
subscribers
maybe now i'm over 200 000 subscribers
and that blow up was absolutely insane
but it was
because of all of that hard work all of
the mistakes that i made in the
beginning i mean
you can go back and you can watch my
videos they're not great i had
a lot to learn i had to learn the
algorithm seo on youtube
and i also had to learn what made me
different
and if you're at the point where you're
like my videos aren't anything special
i don't know why someone would watch my
video over someone else's video
you really need to hone in and figure
out what you uniquely
like what do you have to actually bring
to the table what is something different
that you can offer and for me
it was creating videos that were a bit
more
interesting like i like watching vlogs i
like watching lifestyle
content and i was like how can i
incorporate these tips and at first i
was talking about blogging and pinterest
like i said i was a blogger
i was like how can i make these videos
that are sharing tips and helpful
information
how can i make them interesting and that
then turned into the videos that i now
create once i learned how to grow on
youtube by talking about blogging and
pinterest i then started to teach people
about youtube because
i learned a couple of things and it was
a long journey
i mean a lot can happen in a year but
also
no growth can happen in two years so
back to what i was saying earlier you
have to be determined you have to stick
with it but
also the main tip is figure out what the
heck makes you different and why someone
would want to watch
your videos want to know the exact
strategies sean cannell and the think
media team used to consistently get over
3.5 million views on youtube every month
learn the proven steps and the newest
youtube money making strategies
at growest video live's virtual
conference get your tickets today at
growthvideolive.com
yeah and vanessa i think you did this so
well when you started your channel
i think people maybe underestimate the
amount of strategy
that went into how you've been able to
grow so quickly not just on youtube
but as a business woman and i just want
to first just say congratulations and to
honor you and say
you are really someone that i see has a
huge and bright future for teaching
other people how to do this because
you come at this with such a marketer's
mindset
so walk me through that first year you
know you really came at this and you
were making videos making videos making
videos figured out what your target
audience's problem
was and then bam was able to go right
into
profiting off of youtube walk me through
what that looked like
yeah so the first thing that i want to
say for anyone who's starting out
is already start building an email list
i think one of the smartest things that
i did by accident
was i wanted to launch my website my
website wasn't ready yet
and so i put like a little wait list
just for my website to launch
even though i had no audience and my
very first video i was already
shouting out my website and getting
people on a waitlist and that's how i
was able to collect
the initial emails and so i look back at
that i'm like oh my gosh that was like
one of the best
accidents that i ever made like i didn't
think too much of it but now that i know
what i know i'm like
oh my gosh vanessa you are brilliant you
are so smart
and so the first thing is make sure
you're already learning about
building that email list and some of you
guys might be wondering what i don't
even check my emails what's so important
about that blah blah blah
well the reason why is because youtube
tick tock
instagram facebook you know all these
platforms they could just poof
go down one day disappear one day there
was that one time
last year where like facebook instagram
and whatsapp
all just shut down for like a solid two
days and people were freaking out
or even um a couple weeks or just a
couple months ago people were saying
that tick tock was going to get banned
you know who's to say that might not
happen to youtube and when you actually
collect
emails now you have a contact list of
anyone who is interested in your contact
in your content and so when you do
switch a platform or when something
happens
you can immediately contact them and so
that's just one tactical thing that
anyone can get started doing right now
is to start collecting emails and so
that was the first thing that i did
and then in terms of my journey of
monetizing again it was me
really creating videos that would suit a
target audience and i really just let
youtube do
its thing right i wanted youtube to tell
me
what people wanted from me i'm a very
data-driven person
and so for me before i even thought
about monetization of course everyone
you know who starts a youtube channel
and most people are watching this are
probably interested in making a living
off of this and being their own boss
well look at your analytics youtube will
tell you
the demographics of the people who are
interested in your content what they're
searching for in order to find you
your videos are also really great
indicators based off of the views based
off of the watch time and all of that
of what people are actually interested
in from
you and so once you actually figure that
out and it's gonna take some time and
that's another mistake that i see some
people making is like right off the bat
they're like
how am i gonna monetize this thing let
it chill for like three months at
the first three months or so or your
first 10 videos just focus on being a
really great content creator focus on
the intricacies of talking in front of a
camera just like how catherine had to
overcome
with her being shy on video or you know
practice
scripting practice being as efficient as
possible practice your editing
your first three months is really for
you to be a youtuber
and actually create content and see
where it goes see how confident you get
and then afterwards after three months
or so you're gonna get some solid data
probably that will help you inform your
monetization decisions beyond just
adsense revenue
and so for me i noticed that one of my
videos which was about instagram
started to get a massive viewing um it
went viral it was going really really
well and luckily there i also attached
a lead magnet to collect emails and so
overnight
my email list went from a couple hundred
people to all of a sudden
20 000 people who suddenly want
instagram content and that's when i
realized
oh goodness i'm on to something i have
like 20 000 people who are wanting this
what can i do with these emails what can
i do with these people
and so that's when i started launching
my one-on-one coaching program
and one thing that you have to realize
is most content creators especially if
you're focused on
you know teaching people things or
delivering massive value doesn't matter
if you're teaching people instagram
social media and whatnot
even if it's like teaching people how to
be a hair stylist or
you doing makeup videos or whatnot or
you
like i think heather told me that
earlier on she had another panel with
people who are like in construction
and plumbing and all that stuff whatever
it is that you're teaching on youtube
you can absolutely monetize it there's
always going to be people out there who
want
more than your free content they want
more than a 10 minute video they want
you they want your advice they want your
mentorship they want the full a to z
of how to do something you can hack away
and watch as many free youtube videos as
you want on how to build your youtube
channel
and everything but it's gonna take you a
very long time to diy that
with just free content and paid content
whether that's mentorship or whether
that's signing up for a program
or whatnot that actually gives you the
entire roadmap so that you don't have to
waste time
making tons of mistakes that someone
else can just teach you not to make
and so for me i realized that and that's
when i started to offer one-on-one
services i offered one-on-one mentorship
for other people who wanted to grow
their instagram
and then the next phase that happened
was
you can only go so far with 101 services
there's only one of you
right and so i started realizing oh my
goodness i'm trading a lot of time
for money with working with these
clients i have a wait list of people i'm
booked out
i'm burnt out and so what am i going to
do with all of this demand
and that's when i realized aha let me
package
everything that i've been teaching my
clients let me package some of the
things that i've been teaching on you to
put it in order make it
even juicier even more content and i
created a
course i created a digital product and
now that product sells
passively and the best part about
youtube and why i love youtube so much
is once you put up a video it stays on
youtube for a very long time
and people search for it youtube will
sometimes even push it up in the
algorithm how many of you
have gone through your page and you see
videos from years ago being presented to
you
youtube algorithm is weird but it's
amazing very different than an algorithm
like
instagram instagram is really based off
of recency
and so you only really see content
that's fresh and new whereas youtube
will always push
old content and so when you have a
product that you sell
and you optimize your description box to
link people to your product or you
pin your comment inside your youtube
video that also links to your product
you can potentially sell that product
passively
and create passive income for yourself
and so that's why i really hope that
by the end of grow with video that you
are inspired to not just start that
youtube channel
but also really begin to think about how
am i going to create a
business out of this beyond just hoping
and waiting that i'm gonna get monetized
on youtube
i was making money before i even got
monetized and so that's kind of
the journey for me and i really hope
that you guys can take something out of
that
how did you manage a blog and a youtube
channel
so for me i found a way to really
integrate my content and a lot of people
will recommend you to
cross post so if you have a youtube
video you can also post it on instagram
now
i didn't really do that but i thought of
okay what is my book post idea
what am i going to include in a blog
post and then what youtube video can
relate to that now at first
i wasn't really good with this strategy
i
basically just recreated the blog post
in youtube
format and my videos didn't do well like
i said it took me
a year and a half before i got a
thousand subscribers on youtube
so i made a lot of mistakes but
basically if i was creating
a blog post talking about pinterest
because i used to talk about pinterest a
lot and
i was saying okay here's a pinterest
strategy i would create a youtube video
that then related to that blog post so
once i was getting traffic to that blog
post i was also getting traffic to my
youtube channel and
it was definitely hard to balance
everything but i will say when i was
first getting started
the amount of time i spent on my youtube
videos was nothing compared to what i
spend now
and the quality of my videos weren't as
good so now i'm
really focused on my youtube channel i
am all in on youtube and
that's where basically all of my energy
goes so i think you need to learn to
time manage if you can find a way to
make them work well together
that's going to help you as well as save
you time
yes so important time management is the
key to planning
all of this and taking content seriously
and i want to pass this question off to
vanessa vanessa you said you were a data
driven person and anna bonita from the
comments says
i'm so overwhelmed with the analytics
the graphs and the numbers and all of
the big words
what is the easiest way to understand it
all and you know
youtube is not something that they teach
in school so vanessa how does she
learn about all of these different
analytics and what actually matters
google is your best friend i will be
very honest when i first started
especially after they switched from
classic to like the new studio i was
like
oh my gosh this is a lot of analytics
here and i even had to like google
a couple things but after you start
googling and you
really start paying attention even watch
tutorials on how other people are
tracking their data
one thing that was really helpful for me
is just not being so overwhelmed with
all of the data points you don't have to
care about everything
like i don't care if my audience is
mostly on mobile or on desktop there's
certain stats for me
personally that i don't spend a lot of
time looking at
but there are stats that i like to look
at consistently
for example i like to look at how my
thumbnails are doing
so for me i look at my click-through
rate for all of my videos to really
understand which videos
are doing well especially for my
thumbnails and
also i also like to look at audience
retention and you guys can take notes of
this you can
google it one big thing when it comes to
not just being a youtuber but starting
your own business
is being resourceful and google was my
best friend for like
months and it still is my best friend um
but audience retention i like to
actually look
at when i look at my videos individually
where my audience
is dropping off or where there's peaks
in your audience retention that shows
you that they're
going back to a certain point in your
video maybe you said something
and just understanding my audience
retention rate has really helped a lot i
used to do really long intros
up until like this week and i looked at
my my analytics for once
oh that intro is actually making people
click out of the video
i thought it was helping the video and
so now i'm changing my strategy
and so those are the two main things
that i really love to look at
um and so that's why i highly recommend
for you guys to just have that tunnel
vision on
take the few like five key analytics
that you care about that you think will
move the needle
and these five key analytics may change
from month to month or quarter to
quarter you might change your your
strategy for me for the longest time i
didn't really care about my thumbnails
until i realized that my click-through
rate compared to other youtubers wasn't
that great
and so now i'm paying attention right um
another stat that i love looking at is
how people are finding me i
really leveraged that in the beginning
stages of my channel i don't necessarily
look at that anymore
because me myself as a creator i have
evolved my priorities and i've evolved
just generally but when i was first
starting and once i had a few
more data points to collect i really
really enjoyed looking at
um the traffic sources and what people
are actually searching in the search bar
in order to find my videos
because in the beginning nobody knows me
right and so obviously they're finding
my videos because they're typing certain
keywords and that's when i realized
ah a lot of people are typing in
instagram stuff youtube stuff
how to grow their following how to not
lose followers and that helped me
really ramp up my channel by looking at
that data
versus now it's not as relevant for me
because i've grown such a big following
that people search my name mostly versus
just searching for content ideas or
searching for certain keywords
and so i highly recommend again to
understand
what all the analytics mean but just
focus on like
three to five analytics that you track
consistently until your strategy changes
and that was such a great tip vanessa
about just using
the best website in the world google
right that's how we learned so much
about how to use
youtube and one thing i want to let you
know is that we have
a an amazing company that we love to
partner with it's called vid iq
and we have a special code for you
called vidiq.com forward slash
grow and what's great about vid iq is
that
when you get the boost program you're
actually able to
not only just type in keywords to see
how are people searching for things but
there's some amazing analytics in there
like when's the best
time you should be posting on the
platform and some different things about
what videos are performing better and
why so they give you different analytic
points to look for but
again don't get overwhelmed by the
amount of analytics to be looking at i
love how vanessa said
choose three to five to look at and then
keep growing
keep going keep posting videos all right
i'm gonna pass it off to
another question from from sofia style
but hey
are you getting value out of this video
make sure you hit the like button and
let us know in the chat
what is one aha moment that you've had
from tonight's session
with vanessa and katherine but catherine
this question is for you
uh oh wow it just it just popped away
but hey how
does someone avoid burnout by making
videos say
while they're in college or just how
does someone just avoid burnout in
general
being a content creator that has to stay
consistent on the platform
for me we're gonna go back to the time
management thing when
i first got started with youtube or just
my brand in general i was terrible with
time management as well as productivity
i thought that if i was sitting at my
desk i thought if i was on
instagram leaving comments responding to
dms i thought that that was productive
and i found that i was working really
really long hours and i was working late
into the night or like i said on
saturdays i was waking up at 5am
and that was going to lead me to a point
of burnout
now there are certain things like when i
am about to launch a product or
when i am i've got a deadline on a video
for sponsorship
there are times when yes i will work
myself hard but i am now
a hyper productive person so when i am
at my desk when i am in my office i am
working i am in the zone and i am
focused and i think you need to
understand
the difference of being actually
productive
compared to i'm trying to grow i'm
trying to do all these things and you're
actually not doing it so
for everyone it's a little bit different
for me burnout how i avoid it
is by not working really late at night i
don't wake up first thing in the morning
and go on my computer and get to work i
need to have that self-care time and
especially during a pandemic guys
having self-care is so so important your
mental health comes first because
without you
without you being in a good place like
you can't pour from an empty cup so
you really need to prioritize yourself
now if you are in school
and you're trying to maintain a youtube
channel as well as good grades
one thing i would recommend is a lot of
people will say i need to upload three
videos a week like if i want to grow i
need to upload two or three videos a
week but
if you can't stick to that uploading
schedule back down to only
one video a week but make sure you
actually stick to it so you need to set
realistic expectations on yourself and
then maybe once you've graduated and if
you can take youtube full-time or maybe
if you then go and you have a part-time
job that you can still devote time to
your youtube channel
maybe you can upload more youtube videos
and that's great but you just have to be
realistic with yourself and set
expectations that you can stick to
because i think
once you start breaking that once you
start breaking those
commitments to yourself basically it's
easy to
stop it's really easy for you to just
stop uploading and quit
and if you want to really become a
youtuber if you want to
be successful on this platform you need
to be able to stick with it
man thank you so much for that catherine
it is really important right now to just
remember that
this is i always say your race your pace
and you may see other youtubers you know
like vanessa who's pumping out content
or like you catherine just pumping out
content
and that might not be the season of life
you're in i'm gonna speak to all the
moms right now because i'm the mom on
the channel
and i need you to know that you might
see people like vanessa or like
catherine that are able in the season of
life that they're in to be able to
devote a lot of time to it but again
your race
your pace and making sure that you you
see that youtube is a marathon and not
a sprint if you want to be a content
creator if you want to make change in
the world by getting on video
and getting your message out there you
have to know this is not overnight
right this is not going to be something
that's going to happen right away
it's going to take a lot of hard work
it's going to take a lot of long hours
it's going to take a lot of dedication
it's going to take
not feeling like you're actually making
progress but
as you keep going both vanessa and
catherine are a testament to
the value of just staying consistent
seeing the dream knowing that it's there
and keep
going after it and i want to wrap it up
tonight vanessa we have so many people
on the chat right now
say hello to vanessa if you're from
vanessa's tribe
give her some love in the chat right now
and vanessa
i want you to speak to the person right
now who is afraid to start i want you to
speak to the person
right now who knows that they need to be
doing this and they're just afraid and
really what you wish you would have
known if you were that person
just starting today i think
one important thing is to really
understand that what you aren't
changing you're choosing right so
every day or every month or every year
that you're complaining
about other people being on youtube
being more successful than you
or that fact that they just started or
you complaining
that ah last year was i should have
started that year i should have started
that month
i should have done it during you know
when i had time and now i don't have
time you know what you aren't changing
you are essentially
choosing that outcome for yourself right
and so you have to step
into that energy where you're like you
know what today i'm choosing me
today i'm choosing my future today i'm
choosing
to be on youtube to be a content creator
or a business owner
and that's just one thing i definitely
want to say to all of you guys
no excuses i think that's like the theme
of today
especially catherine mentioning many
times about persistency and all that
so i want to say that the second thing i
want to say
is and this is maybe a little bit less
inspirational
but i wanted to say it while heather was
talking and all that stuff
is kind of not comparing yourself to
other
youtubers like myself or catherine or
someone who has a team
someone who does it full time i'm
talking to those of you who maybe are
working a nine-to-five and you want to
start youtube and all of that
don't compare yourself to other people
and also understand what you actually
want to do
with the platform and that's something i
wish that
i knew earlier that i could tell my own
students that i could tell my own
clients
earlier for me i'm on youtube because
i've always wanted to be
a content creator influencer and i just
so happen
to have a business because of it right
and so because
i my intention going into youtube was
that i wanted to get the plaque
and i wanted the subscribers that's why
i post
that many times that i post because i i
care about that vanity metric i've
always always always wanted to be a
youtuber
that had the plaque right but if your
intention
going into youtube is just making money
is just getting visibility for your
small business is just to make sure
you have a little bit of exposure on
evergreen and that you can't you don't
have to do facebook ads let's say
then post a video once a month let's say
because
the beauty of youtube and why i adore
this platform is
its seo capabilities the fact like i
said earlier
youtube doesn't just value recency
people are finding
old videos of yours every day i get
comments and like videos that i posted
last year and i still get leads from
that and so it's really important
when you're starting just understand
what you want and there's no problem in
that
you either want to be an influencer in
which case maybe you do have to work a
little harder you do have to be more
consistent posting once a week to get
that subscriber rate up because people
want to see that you have an active
channel
or you can take the route where hey i
just want exposure for my business
and the most i can commit is once a
month and i'm just happy that i'm
getting that exposure
so really really understand why you are
starting youtube
you don't have to care so much about the
subscribers if you don't want to
you can just use youtube as that
evergreen machine
that's bringing you leads to your
business so that's what i have to say
wow vanessa what fire the chat was just
on fire during that one and i just love
the points that you have
uh when it comes to actually getting
started and not comparing
exactly right that is what we want to
really get that message across because
it's just so important to be
who you are and make the content that
you know is going to help people so
katherine i want to pass it off to you
final message if you're part of
katherine's tribe and you're here
watching tonight
light her up in the chat right now she
is doing phenomenal she started saying
she was super nervous guys
let's give it up for katherine she did
an amazing job catherine the person
right now is just getting started
they are scared they know they need to
be doing this they're making all of the
excuses
that we have already made what advice do
you have for them
for getting started right now okay
i've got two the first one stop
watching content and start creating it
now
this could be silly because my channel i
help you guys grow on youtube i help you
guys
start a youtube channel i've got all the
tips tricks everything i have learned
that has helped me to get to the point
that i'm at today
but i think so many people get caught up
they want to be as prepared as possible
they want to buy all of the equipment
and they want to basically go at it
already running and i think it gets to a
point where
yes you're making your excuses you're
already holding yourself back but you
may not realize that
you are actually just over preparing and
that is another way that you're holding
yourself back so i think yes it is
important
to educate yourself and i think it's
good to watch other creators and see
what's making them successful on the
platform but
if you're at the point where you're just
watching a ton of videos and you're like
no this is research this is going to
help me
not creating videos like that's just
hurting you you're just holding yourself
back
the second thing is once you actually
start and you create that first video
do not check your analytics every single
day and i think that
every single youtuber has done this it's
so easy to do you wake up in the morning
and you want to see if you got more
subscribers you want to see
how your video did and they have the
they rank your last 10 videos and how
it's performing and i'm not going to lie
i look at those analytics i'm very much
to an analytic person but
if you put your value in your analytics
and you put the success of the youtube
video on the views that you're getting
or the success of your youtube channel
and the number of subscribers you are
getting
you are going to put yourself in just
this toxic
mindset that is going to push you to the
point of quitting
and youtube it's a marathon it's not a
sprint
for me i didn't see real growth for over
a year and a half
and then it blew up like crazy but you
have to be able to
see that your numbers aren't growing or
stop looking at your analytics and don't
care that your numbers aren't growing
but
keep going because if you look at those
analytics oh my gosh you are going to
drive yourself
crazy and you're just going to wonder
why like why aren't people watching my
videos am i not good enough all this
stuff and that's just such a toxic
mindset
so two things stop watching videos start
creating videos and stop checking your
analytics every day
[Music]
well i hope you enjoyed that sit down
interview with vanessa lau and catherine
manning we'll leave in the description
box below and in the show notes how you
can follow them online but
i want to remind you that grow with
video live the virtual experience
is coming up quick so if you've not
gotten your tickets yet
you want to go to growwithvideolive.com
so you can get that ticket
and if you go to thinkmediapodcast.com
enter in a submission for a
free ticket by reviewing our podcast on
the apple
podcast you can come to the virtual
experience with that free
ticket if you win so go to
growthvideolive.com if you want to see
all the details about the conference
and go to think thinkmediapodcast.com if
you want to enter in
to win a free ticket now your action
steps are what do you need to do next
for your youtube channel after listening
to this interview
with both of these ladies sharing their
journey to full-time freedom
i want to pass the question off to you
did you write down your next action step
i loved how vanessa said that you know
really was
as she was a barista it was her just
staying consistent and knowing that she
had a vision for her future
have you written down that vision yet or
katherine manning who
jumped into creating content in a
different way
when she was seeing the other content
creators in her space like us here at
think media
she wanted to separate herself from the
pack and really figure out what made her
different
have you figured out what made you
different yet in your niche these are
all different things that you can
start to take action on today and we're
going to be diving more into that at
growth video live
virtual experience we've got some
amazing content just like this
waiting for you at that experience so
make sure you get your tickets for that
and if you have already left a review
over on apple
i want to thank you because it's my
favorite thing to do every single week
to be able to
read your reviews and to hear what
you're getting out of our podcast you
know we created this podcast here for
think media
because we wanted to go deeper in beyond
things like cameras and audio and
lighting
we wanted to go into things like mindset
and trend surfing
and interviews just like this so i'm
grateful for you for being a part
of our think community and for leaving
reviews on the podcast it helps other
people know
if this is the right one for them this
one today comes from
the stories we wish to tell they said
just what i've been looking for well hey
i'm so glad you're here because you're
just what i've been looking for
i'm so glad i finally started listening
to the think podcast
it has been coming across my radar for a
while and while i've always been
interested in the work that they do
i've only recently started listening to
the podcast the show is full of so much
value
there is a lot of similar shows out
there but heather and sean's
personalities and perspectives
really set this show apart definitely
check the show
out now thank you so much for leaving
that review
and man isn't that the story of our
lives we see things coming through all
the time
but we have to be in the right place and
the right time to really start to absorb
that information and that's why we
wanted to make this podcast for you
because we know that there are is a lot
of content out there when it comes to
growing on youtube
but we wanted to separate ourselves and
say hey how can we go deeper
how can we share our perspective how can
we share our failures and our successes
and our stories and our friends stories
with you so i'm grateful that you left
that review and i want to encourage you
that if you're brand new to this podcast
to subscribe wherever you're listening
so that it shows up on your radar
next week well thanks so much for being
here and for listening
and for taking us along on the journey
of your
youtube channel i love seeing your
successes inside of
video ranking academy and my favorite
thing to do
is to see you at grow with video live
because that is where we set aside the
time
to take action on our channels i'll
catch you in the next episode thanks for
being here
not growing on youtube learn the newest
strategies for getting views and the
best proven ways to make money
at grow with video live a two day
virtual conference
and you can get your tickets today at
growwithvideolive.com
you